- [Voiceover] Two spheres,
one with radius seven,
and one with radius seven,
and one with radius four
are tangent to each other.
If P is any point on one sphere
and Q is any point on the other sphere,
what is the maximum possible length of PQ?
So, let's think about this.
So, let me draw the
sphere with radius seven.
And obviously the sphere is
a three dimensional object.
And I'm going to try and draw it
in two dimensions.
So, a circle you can kind of use
a cross section of it.
So, this right over here,
cross section at its
widest point of the sphere.
So, it has radius seven.
So, it has radius seven
and it is tangent to another sphere
that has radius four.
So, it has radius, it has radius four.
So, the other one might look something
like this, once again.
It's a cross section.
It's tangent at exactly this point.
And I've just drawn circles,
but then you can imagine
these are actually spheres.
I'll try to give it some actual depth,
so that you recognize
that these are not just,
you can imagine balloons
or balls of this shape.
Now, P is any point on one sphere
and Q is any point on the other sphere.
And we want the maximum length of PQ.
So, we want to get these points P and Q
as far away as possible from each other.
So, if I was just
dealing with two circles,
I'd stick P right over
here, all the way here.
And I would stick Q,
I would stick Q all the way over there
on the other circle.
And so the distance
between them is going to be
essentially the sum of the two diameters.
So, it's going to be,
it's going to be 14 plus,
14 plus eight and 14 plus eight,
14 plus eight is going to be equal to 22.
And so, if I can do that with two circles
of these radii, I could obviously do these
as spheres as well.
You could imagine these
are the cross sections
of those spheres.
So, I can get to a distance of 22,
but am I sure that that's
the furthest distance?
Well, you could reason
through it that look
if you were to try to
bring P out a little bit
more unto the surface
here, on the surface,
yeah there's going to be
a little bit of distance
now that it's kind of
going out of the page,
if you're going out of
the surface right here.
But, it's getting closer,
essentially, along the page.
So, maybe those two things trade off,
or maybe this really is
the maximum distance.
And if you're taking this
on a standardized test,
this could become a very
involved thought process.
And you start saying,
"well, how do I prove
"that this is absolutely
the furthest distance?"
But, many times, the
test itself is designed
so that you don't have to prove it.
Because notice, we could definitely find
a distance of 22.
This we can definitely
find between two points
on these two surfaces.
And notice, that is the largest of all
of your possible choices.
So, we would go with the largest
of all of their possible choices.
This would be a little bit more confusing.
You would have to be a little bit more
rigorous with yourself and say,
"Well, do I really know that."
If they had a choice that said 23
or a choice that said 22 times
the square root of two,
or something like that.
But, the fact that you can definitely
can get these points to be
22 away from each other,
and that is the largest
of all of the choices.
That's a pretty good clue that that is
the maximum possible length of PQ.
And in a future video, I
can do a more in depth proof
that this is actually
going to be the case.